[Musique]
dites-nous ce qui vous est arrivé
me rappelle pas
[Musique]
avant de te connaître je savais pas trop
quoi faire de ma vie
aujourd'hui c'est comme si j'allais
quelque part
[Musique]
alors bon je sais pas vraiment où mais
je sais que je vais y aller avec toi
est-ce que tu es prête à nous dire ce
qui t'est arrivé
tu étais seul
je voulais dire je m'en souviens pas
[Musique]
pression qu'il y a un truc qui va
vraiment pas chez elle
ce que j'essaie de te dire c'est que
[Musique]
tu es la femme de ma vie en route
qu'est-ce qui va pas chez toi
[Musique]
je t'aime mais parfois les gens changent
un jour moi aussi je changerai peut-être
que tu aimeras cette nouvelle version de
moi
[Musique]
ou peut-être que non
ça va pour tout dire j'avais comme
l'impression de ne pas être moi-même
[Musique]
va être